[Musique]
championnat cycliste de la caraïbe la
19e édition se déroule à cuba l'année
dernière en république dominicaine
c'est mikel stanislas qui s'était imposé
sur la route halfway de frontistes vous
êtes le président du comité cycliste de
martinique vous serez très attendu ici à
cuba absolument je fais que constater
ainsi que vous qu'il ya beaucoup plus de
participants cette année ça sort de
partout j'ai pas dis pas que cuba est
placé en quelques pans dans le centre et
puis c'est plus facile d'arriver par le
panama aussi par miami avec très peu de
financement sont devenues vous défendre
le titre avec mikel san islas une équipe
constituée de quatre garçons je pense
que nous serons en mesure de bien
figurer et pourquoi pas d'être sur le
podium
on prépare les hurricanes ont
brillamment et la couleur des combats
la banque
dimanche 68 km en ligne pour les filles
et 123 km 500 pour les hommes